welcome to this video playing wrote King
he know he doesn't have a name in there
right no no this is all text yeah this
is a side account of some strong GM he's
on for ages on the ICC aha f4 yeah and I
wasn't even aware that this is this is a
move
hmm interesting Bishop g5 94 I've played
many times what is the idea
c5 maybe he wants to go c5
yeah why not he's 65 could be
interesting
who came let's go g6 yeah I never saw
Bishop f4 yeah this interesting tries to
set up position similar to the two the
recursion with reversed colors
yep maybe this and then try to play 45
okay
I'd like to relate you 5 him I know it
takes hmm
yeah no I'd rather rather take take with
this at least I'm managing to play e5 on
at least them he needs to make some
concession let's go F 65
yeah this night a forum okay b6 is of
course a whole in my position but I'm
not sure that the night is doing so much
there
I just play rook b8 or okay I'm not sure
the night is not doing so much it you
can take d7 but other than that it's
just pretty there but is it actually
doing something yeah to a seminar to be
a Janna let's go here nuts things like
that you can spend ages on
93 and tried to secure the night on f5
and one idea and additional ideas a5
Bishop CA to a6 it's still e5 actually
it's not out of the picture this is Wow
very sharp move hard to believe really
that this should be good for white so
weakening the position enormous ly
difficult very difficult so the question
is what what to do with the bishop I
cannot
maybe thinking about it you're hired
I really can't let you fire but wait I
can take and play e5 this is this is
actually interesting and okay and I need
to use the book here on h2 Luke edge to
check shouldn't be bad so this is
protected
you need to get the Queen involved Queen
Queen h8 h for something like that but
if I go Queen h8 he might play 97 yeah
well okay and let him play that Queen
frf Queen h4 ID this must be must be
some attack some serious attack check
I'm not obliged to take it this is what
I'm talking about
can you give check here and take or
maybe Queen f2
okay it's not enough from them
threatening queen f1 greener for now and
possible to calculate at least for me
check
check this was my idea I didn't see that
one
which isn't necessarily a problem but
and playing without the a7 rook and
without a minute this is the the the the
biggest thing
check
twin g6 cream g6 Montague time warning
and I can take it too but he's got Queen
g6 unbelievable
check
check
yes sir
yeah it was it wasn't possible for me
with the we're this time to play this
black and silver state sometimes made
next move here
yeah and I'm 100% sure that I had a win
but no idea and in this in this time
it's it's too much for me I need a bit
more time to to do the calculation in
these dispositions so let's check if
I've is the first win here but okay yeah
this is just a theoretical thing I mean
you need to play it in a blitz game but
just objectively five wins for black
okay not quite sure why actually
alright so it's an attractive move of
course if you get this in this is one
one very important point
yeah Mike it's a material up pawn up and
I'm just in its position so okay but
let's check this this started not
working yeah after this yeah white is
winning according to the computer check
no black is winning and it wants to take
a one yeah hmm yeah okay no way no way a
human is going to take on a one
tween a one- form now no chance is that
it says that this is perfectly winning
for black something like this can Jack
here what the heck
okay I took on their song okay this wins
as well but it's obviously tricky and
now okayed just continuing yeah I'm an
exchange of itself it's it's it's also
just a material issue at thirty seconds
and this is this actually yeah it's
doing Jack we came but ninety form
yeah I saw that but did I take e5 I was
I was so hypnotized by this threat that
I I didn't see that I said this was one
idea but okay this is I made great Nick
Smith for some reason I cannot get I
cannot take the move backs know why
strange okay but I guess enough analysis
for the scam really really complicated
thanks for watching